[Music]
hello hello everyone and welcome
Hadoop and its ecosystem has become
increasingly important to businesses of
every type Hadoop holds the promise that
it will unlock the value of your data
and give you the insights that will help
you flourish your business now you're
here so maybe you're aware of or you
personally experienced that overheads of
managing Hadoop infrastructures are not
not so small as the number and
sophistication of the workloads we run
increases so does the operational
overhead of our clusters to this
increase in the overhead undermines the
core value proposition that Hadoop
brings to the table essentially takes
away focus from the data on to how to
run the cluster this is where Google
cloud platform and cloud data proc come
in my name is Jelena Piazza Karpovich
I'm tech lead and manager at Google and
today we will see how your migration to
cloud and incremental changes to the way
you run your Hadoop and spark we're
closed
can let you preserve the power of the
open source system that you built but
and reduce the operational complexity
allowing you to refocus on the data this
is a journey migration to the cloud
doesn't have one weight that works for
everyone
there are many valid paths to take we
will highlight some overarching
guidelines and the principles and
identify useful building blocks that
will make the migration to cloud easier
and smoother and allow you to benefit
earlier from the new stack so let's
begin with what is Google Cloud Data
proc Google cloud data proc is managed
loop and spark service its goal is to
help you refocus your efforts to your
data instead of managing the cluster
data proc achieves this by being the
past easy and cost effective what do I
mean by that imagine a new version of
her
group is coming out it promises to make
your critical workload ten times faster
sounds great right what would it take
for you to deploy this new version of
Hadoop in your data center think of the
testing validation qualification and
everything else be data proc this would
be one line command command or
alternatively a few clicks about 90
seconds after that command line you
would have a brand new data a cluster
with the version that you want and you
would be ready to canary your workloads
even at the production scale the speed
and simplicity at which you can run this
at which you can run and start the
clusters lends itself to
cost-effectiveness because you can run
the cluster and the resources only when
you need them
there is whole spectrum of approaches on
running Hadoop on GCP starting with an
on premise right we can have any of the
of these options there and where you're
on this spectrum depends on whether you
treat GCP as infrastructure as a service
or as a platform as a service along this
spectrum GCP works with many Platt
partners that will help you migration
and you don't have to be alone on this
path so let's look at what the data
protocol the data Pro works in houses
build data Pro Clair's the features on
top of the standard Hadoop stack between
the layer Hadoop Slayers we insert the
monitoring statuses configuration
options things like that that augments
the Hadoop stack and make it more
manageable
we built our functionality using native
open source api's which means that
whatever you did for your own
customization in your own cluster will
work in data proc
you will have a full-power how you
access these clusters you can use your
standard api's that you're used to like
Hadoop command line you know SSH to the
master or you can use our REST API s and
our UI third-party tools that we are
integrated with it's it's your choice
our distro is based on the big top and
it comes with a Hadoop spark hive and
pig by default they are enabled
immediately we provide you with ability
to enable Pez Zeppelin and Kafka via
something we call the initialization
actions so imagine you're in a place
where you are enticed with a cloud and
you want to try it out so what should be
your next step you should be planning
your proof-of-concept boc during the
Pusey you will have to think about what
will it take to move your on-premise
solution to the cloud you will think
about mechanics you know how can I do
this but we encourage you to think
bigger you should think about the
opportunities to simplify your stack as
well and as you proceed with pure seed
this design is going to be really
important concretely on thinking the
bigger in your on-premise set of Hadoop
clusters are likely the core of your
data platform in cloud they're just one
of the building blocks and you can have
many building blocks and many different
building blocks example of the building
blocks we'll mention today and you
probably heard today also things like
GCS bigquery BigTable pub/sub dataflow
stackdriver machine learning right
all of these can eventually become parts
of your platform that's maybe just
starting with the data data proc in
Hadoop right so when you think of
migration you should lift your platform
and you should leverage these things as
well
when starting the POC you need to
identify your high-level goals for the
migration and you want them to be clear
and well understood some of the goals
are in here like cost savings what is
the cost saving mean to you is it the
total cost of ownership or it is the
cost performance balance right like you
want more performance for the same
amount of money what you do depending on
on which of these two goals you care
about more you know it's a pen it will
depend on which of these two goals you
actually have you have concerns about
the scaling elasticity they wanted to
solve that problem by having multiple
clusters or you'll go step further and
your oldest a disaggregate your storage
and compute and then you can have as
many clusters as you want and you can
even throw different tools on your data
right development agility like how do
you handle versioning do you care about
heterogeneous dependencies and etc you
don't have to really when you think of
these goals you you don't have to make
significant changes to your stack but
you want to consciously think of the
goals you have and you know do the
analysis of concretely do the analysis
of the cost and benefits of keeping
something the same or trying to change
it in a process so we now have goals
which is great but we have to understand
our requirements right the
characteristics of your current solution
existence system and also the timeline
that you have in mind for this migration
to get to the requirements you should
look at the tools that you're currently
using what are the components what are
the components you actually want to keep
because some of the components are
really the requirement and some of the
components you added because you had to
it was a hack around the problem you had
right so perhaps that hack doesn't have
to go with you to the cloud maybe there
is a better solution there right
think about the capacity planning you're
gonna use the data proc so you're still
responsible for sizing your clusters
right so think about you know how much
compute you need what are the average
peak and what is their peak and what's
average you the data throughput that you
want to support think of the security
models and finally thinking of the
timeline is important because the
depending on the duration of migration
that you have in mind
you may have to build a hybrid
infrastructure that will host both your
current on prompting and the cloud
cluster okay okay so we talked about the
planning you've done your planning you
have your goals what is the first step
the first step will be the data
migration so usually when you're
thinking of data migration you look at
your storage options and the types of
data you have at cloud we have at GCP we
have quite a few storage solutions the
standard one is Google Cloud Storage
which is our large-scale object store
that is accessible through file based
API we also give you two two flavors of
HDFS one based on the persistent disks
and one on the localized disease then if
you use hive we have a cloud BigTable
right and we have bigquery we also have
spanner and many other products that
could meet your needs
right so you should evaluate them
understand what our benefits and
drawbacks are and then you should look
at your data and usually one of the
first data sets that moves to the cloud
is archival and cold data the staff you
have to take care of but you don't
really use right so that's usually the
first thing that moves to the cloud and
then you start moving parts of the live
hot data and you start computing with it
right you do want to when one thing
that's important is how you access the
data so to choose which storage option
you want you really want to think of the
better
the data set requires random access or
not okay so again the first movers yeah
and one thing to think about is like if
you have to have a hybrid architecture
you need to figure out the solution that
will allow you to keep the same data set
in two places and the partners are
really helpful with that okay okay
so GCS is usually the first GCP solution
you will use so I would like to call out
some differences between GCP and HDFS
I'm assuming you're familiar with the
HDFS so GCP is our object store and for
most parts you can use it as a dropping
replacement for HDFS it has a Hadoop
file system interface all your IR
connectors based you know file input
output format spark context you know
text file etc just work nice thing with
our connector GCS connector is also that
you can install it on your own
on-premise cluster the GCS you will get
a cleaner architecture why because the
data will live outside of your cluster
it will live in our distributed storage
that is replicated across the zones
perhaps multi-regional even if that's
how you want it and you can throw any
compute on it you you're not limited to
you know just the compute that you have
in your cluster right nice another nice
thing of the GCS is that there is no
concept of a name node so if you ever
experience kill ability con you know
issues in your clusters due to name node
performance this is this does not exist
right like there's no such thing here
and you also no longer have a single
point of failure right to optimize GCS
performance conveniently you use the
same approaches like you optimize HDFS
so you want to optimize for bulk and
parallel operations okay
so the pros of GCS are high-throughput
no scaling bottlenecks no single point
of failure and the data can be durable
across the zones in regions right there
are some drawbacks with the fact that
there is no name node and that you're
across the zones and regions your
latency can go up directories in GCS are
simulated so if your application relies
on checking a timestamp of a directory
there's no such thing okay so you either
have to modify the application or you
have to use HDFS right and like objects
on GCS cannot be appended once they are
closed so these are sort of things to
think about about when you want to move
the data sets to GCS right so okay we
want to move the datasets what approach
is going to take well we can push it or
we can pull it right like those are two
generally approaches you can do push
approach is I'm in my own pram cluster I
connect to the GCS via GCS api's and I
copy the data from my cluster to GCS
right it's simple it has a
straightforward security model your data
is encrypted with SSL and it goes
through Internet gateways like this so
you're on your own Prem cluster and you
send your data to GCS okay so that's a
simplest model the downside of this
model is that you're using your computer
non-prime cluster to move the data so if
you were resource constraint on your
cluster this is sort of upset you know
you're you're using more resources right
alternative model is a pull model so in
a pull model I set up the VPN such that
my cloud cluster can access the data on
my own premise cluster you really want
to do this carefully okay and from there
you use the compute in your cloud to
just pull the data from your own Prem
cluster from there the data can go
either on your HDFS
on the in the cloud or to storage or to
bigquery it doesn't matter right
all of these are options the main
difference B is bit you know as in the
security model in the pull approach your
security relies on you setting up the
VPN properly and and ensuring that you
can set up the permissions such that
only you can access that data okay
so let's take a look at some of the
cloud native architect architectural
concepts on your on-prem cluster the
data locality was premium and
essentially you were computing over the
data that existed in your cluster right
that was done for performance reason and
convenience reasons because usually when
you decided you needed a petabyte of
storage you bought a cluster that had a
petabyte of storage and it came with
some CPUs write your computations come
and go in a cluster but your data sits
there so the computation and store and
the data have a very different life
spans for most part so why not just
separate them right why do we have to
tie the computation to the lifespan of
the data right and the the process of
this segregation of storage and compute
is essentially separating data plane
from the computing right
we essentially pull out the data from
the machines so if this is our cluster
we no longer keep a data inside a
cluster but we use GCS bigquery BigTable
spanner
whichever data data store you chose and
our clusters are there for computing and
you know when we're done computing maybe
we can get rid of them hey at the same
time we also like our clusters will
produce some data such as you know
monitoring data and logging data and
stuff like that and that will also live
outside of the cluster it will come out
of it right because we don't want to
keep these this information is useful
even when the computation is done so we
separated from the computation
so this gives you quite a bit of
flexibility on how you manage cluster
lifespan but another thing that it gives
you also is ability to bursting cloud
what I mean by that in cloud you know a
job a task that will take a thousand CPU
hours will cost the same if it runs on a
thousand machines for one hour or on ten
machines 400 hours alright like the math
adds up right like the CPU usage this
kazoo drama usage adds up right but it's
very likely that that value is way more
valuable to you if you waited one hour
for it as opposed to 100 hours right now
if your data was confined on the
machines that are computing the chances
of you being able to throw thousand
machines on it trivially is low but if
you store it on something that's highly
scalable like GCS you can actually throw
this many resources on it and compute
this much faster for the same price
another thing that's feature of data
proc and it's used in GCP are
preemptable VMs preemptable VMs are
regular VMs but google reclaims the
right Google keeps the right to reclaim
them as needed so they can come and go
usually they're they're the because of
this they cost only 20% of the cost of
the VM right so they're significantly
cheaper than the regular VM and there
are certain guaranteed to be preempted
at least once a day okay so with data
proc you know if you don't have a data
proc you would have to deal with these
machines coming and going right you want
your cluster with hundred machines you
have 95 now because five of them were
preempted you have to find another five
right with data proc this is managed for
you automatically so you can have your
data procaster
with the preemptable VMs costing 1/5 of
the compute that you will have with the
data player cluster with the regular VMs
okay and another thing where this is
really useful
is if you separated your storage from
the compute the preemptable viens don't
really cost you any loss like they just
come and go right different computations
have a different resource requirements
so let's imagine that our workload
requires six CPUs and eight gigs of RAM
in Google we have a standard instances
and one is n1 standard 4 which comes
with the 4 CPUs and 4 gigs of RAM there
is n1 hi ma'am which comes with 4 CPUs
and 8 gigs of ram and we have n1
standard 8 which has a cpus and 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 8 gigs of ram right but we need
6 CPUs and 8 gigs of ram so you can
create your data flow cast a class a
data program cluster using custom VMs
which will have 6 CPUs and whatever Ram
you need there I guess these are 4 gig
chips let's assume 8 right so depending
on computation you want to do you can
actually make a VMs fit the size your
computation and just run the data per
cluster with it this custom VMs came out
in March and are pretty neat
technological improvement you don't have
to do any bin packing of your workloads
so now we've seen you know we separated
our data from computation we understand
that we can have a different size
machines so let's take this one idea
further right we can the right size our
clusters based on the use case we have
think of the different for clothes you
do you have a MapReduce ETL you have
some machine learning you do some hive
analytics and you do business reporting
do all these workloads need the same
computational power are some of them
more valuable than others and you're
willing to pay more for those VMs so the
things would finish faster so if you
were willing to pay for business
reporting to use this high-performance
VMs are you willing to
them on MapReduce ETL perhaps perhaps
not so if you think of this cluster as a
building block you can understand that
here you have actually potential for
having four different shaped and
building blocks right so we can have
four clusters with the VMS that look
significantly different have a different
price performance label attached to them
and we can optimize you know for cost we
can optimize for speed and for a
different use case we can choose the
right equation right so this is right
sizing clusters per use case right but
we can take it one step further okay so
we can have a thermal and semi Lingle
long-lived clusters so at the beginning
I said it takes us around 90 seconds to
start the data proc cluster and we'll
demo that soon so this is pretty
immediate right so we can choose a
lifetime of a cluster according to the
work flow
it runs on one end of the spectrum our
thermal clusters those are clusters that
you start to do this computation and
then when the computation is done you
just delete them as simple as that
I know one of our partners does exactly
that they have some custom-made spark
thing that they run every night and it's
pretty significant it uses like around
thousand cores or something so every
night at midnight they spin up thousand
core data per cluster run the
computation and tear it down okay and
then met midnight next following night
they do the same right it's all
automatable the other thing that's nice
if you treat the cluster per computation
like in this a thermal mode is imagine
you have to change the region for
whatever reason right it's essentially
the only have to do in that case is like
well start a cluster in this region and
run jobs there it's as simple as that on
the other end of the spectrum you'll
have the semi long-lived clusters right
and even for them you know they may end
up having some data there you know maybe
you're running your own hive instance or
something so you really need them there
all the time right like they cannot
really go away easily coming back to the
one of the use cases at the beginning
like what does it take to install the
new version right well again a few
clicks of a button and selecting the
preview image for the latest in the
greatest and you start a new cluster you
can start debugging on it you can start
load testing and everything else and
once you're happy just a migrate all
your workflows to this new cluster and
shut down the other one right so a
formal clusters allow you to really
treat computation very differently than
you did on pram but they are not
required it is something that can be
done for you know
if it makes your life simpler if it
doesn't just go ahead and use the semi
long-lived clusters and benefit from our
ability to start the clusters quickly
when you want to test the new versions
okay okay so we settled on couple of
architectural choices how do we actually
manage our cluster in our jobs so data
Brook exposes REST API and the standard
rest API allows you to manage cluster
jobs and operations on the clusters and
we integrate with many third-party tools
like M our job Luigi no chance that all
allow us that that allows you to sort of
handle your clusters using this API
right you can also SSH on your master
node and use your standard Hadoop and
spark commands that you're used to but
we're gonna see how managing data proc
through these API is looked like so can
I have my computer ok so here is a cloud
platform start page our console ok and
we'll go find the data proc from here
the approach is here and this is in our
demo project so there are four projects
right now two of them are in US and two
are in Europe in different zones and I
started the Jelena demo zero just so I
make sure I have one cluster running and
my colleagues run the other ones and we
live in a separate world right like I
can't affect their production or their
demos and they can't affect mine which
is really nice separation sometimes to
have so I want to create the cluster and
here will click on create the cluster
and I'm gonna call it and I'm gonna call
it - I'm gonna run it in Europe because
we are in Europe right now and I'm just
gonna minimally configure it like I'm
gonna reduce the size of the disks and I
mentioned you could try running a new
version and that option exists here so
you can choose the image version and the
preview one is a nicely built we're not
gonna do that we're just gonna keep the
default and I'm gonna click create okay
so here we see my cluster is starting to
being made and at the same time we'll do
an experiment with a command line which
is here and this is essentially the
common line we do g-cloud data per
cluster is create yell and a demo one
with the two workers okay and this
starts the operation so here you can see
two clusters being spin up right like
these two it's readable right
okay and let's see how long does it take
while they're spinning up we can look at
them so here I already have it two
workers so this one probably sped up
fully I can easily get some overview on
the CPU utilization on what workers the
jobs are doing and I can see my
configuration at any given time right I
can check on the jobs but I didn't run
any jobs so there's nothing there right
now okay let's go back to all of them
okay so demo to started demo one is
still spinning up let's check it out
again this one also had only two
instances and I'm guessing it's
essentially done okay so let's open
another tab and we'll go back to that
one so now imagine we want to run a job
okay and we'll run
I have here some spark PI spark hello
world in PI spark okay it just starts a
PI spark and prints hello and world
nothing to X you know too exciting
perfect for demo okay so our cluster
started in like 94 seconds so okay let's
go back here let's run this job using
our API so it copied the files it
started operation and this is running on
demo one so I can check the jobs there
it's running right now and the really
cool thing is that essentially you can
get the live stream of the output and
[Music]
in a few seconds it started you can yeah
you can see it's finished its job and
then printed out hello world now let's
say we wanted to run something slightly
bit more complicated but still demo
Bertie let's compute the value of pi
okay and this one will do run another
spark job with with the thousand tasks
to complete this and this guy will run
on our demo to cluster okay okay so you
can see small spikes in CPU the jobs
that are running this one is running we
have our VM instances again if I click
here I can see it executing and you can
see the this is the number of tasks
it just started so it has zero tasks and
it completed zero and I guess the new
line is hard to add so we'll have a
little bit of noisy output but we just
computed PI that it's one 3.1416 two and
for everyone who knows that it's like
one four one five nine whatever we need
to recompute it better right like this
is not good enough so let's try it
running 50 times bigger problem okay so
instead of thousand tasks let's do 50
thousand tasks okay
yeah so this job with a thousand tasks -
33 seconds we're now running with 50,000
tasks and you know maybe we figure out
whoops this is gonna take you know 50
times 30 seconds I have like seven more
minutes maybe not a good idea
I need more resources so I'll edit the
cluster and instead of two I'll do 100
VMs okay
and I got Sakura this Korra
okay let's 200 is not gonna work but
let's do 14
hmm okay
maybe everyone I selected the wrong zone
sorry ah come on okay let's run it on
the other cluster actually I'm really
upset with this cluster so I'm gonna
delete it okay and and that one is going
to go away and I'm just gonna kill this
guy
and go to the beginning of the line and
change it into run it on demo one and
while we are doing this this cluster is
being deleted with all the artifacts
that it created and this one I'm gonna
increase the more machines because in
this zone I know I have quota come on
okay so the quarters are not cooperating
with me today so let's do 30 notes
although okay thank you so what does it
mean let's look at our reams voila my
extra 30 VMs are showing up and it will
take them a few seconds and this is on
my demo 1 cluster and as they start
appearing you'll see they're faster than
than they originally so in a few seconds
they're all here and now all that has to
happen is that my Hadoop cluster picks
them up and start sending tasks to them
right and while the job is running I
want to show you that we allow you to
see your standard Hadoop UI right like
if you really really really love your
Hadoop UI and you know how to debug
things on it
we allow you to to do so you just need
to set up the VPN it's a pretty
straightforward it's documented on a
page and on this guy we can check the
nodes and at this point it started with
2 but now we have way more nodes and
they're all processing our job
okay so with this let's switch back to
the slides
okay so you've seen me use a few ways of
accessing REST API some from common
lines some from UI it's integrated with
the tools like Luigi and mr jobs so you
can use those tools as well to run the
jobs on a data proc there are three ways
you can actually run the jobs like I did
not demo the Hadoop one but essentially
on that one you were just SSH on your
master and be able to run like you
usually do you see me a few times
unsuccessfully resized the cluster but
then I was successful but the the
challenge was the quota I selected the
wrong zone and but the point is like it
was a click away right and that's a edit
and change the number of machines right
thing I did not show you all is that
these clusters are integrated with
stackdriver stackdriver allows you to
set up the monitoring and logging so
essentially all the information gathered
about your cluster will be preserved
there and it can be turned into really
nice dashboards it can be set up such
that it causes alerts you know so if you
have someone monitoring your production
they can actually be alerted if things
are not going the way they're supposed
to and you'll be able to access your
logs even after you delete the cluster
and to put it all together we initially
will probably just start with moving the
data away and putting it in a cloud and
then we'll start experimenting with
workloads that are maybe bursty or new
applications we want to run as we go
along we may end up building a hybrid
infrastructure that you want that where
you'll host both your on-prem and the
GCP clusters and finally you might end
up in a native cloud state where all
your computations all your data lives in
the cloud and operates well with all
other building blocks that we have in
Google to start we have a good
documentation on cloud google.com data
proc
we also have a many ways to get a help
through our documentation through our
release notes stack overflow we scrub it
all every day and make sure we answer
the questions we have email lists that
you can send emails to google cloud
support and another one that is not
listed here is our partners so if you if
this looks as a daunting task you can
partner with many good companies that
are listed on our website that can help
you with this so with that I'm happy to
take any questions it seems like the
standard way here is to ask questions
after the talk so thank you all for
coming